[Applause]
good afternoon everyone and a very warm
welcome to the foreign correspondents
club in Japan and thank you very much
for coming today to this press
conference I've got a couple of
housekeeping things to mention first if
we um if you could all remember to put
your phones on mute or otherwise keep
them quiet to save interruptions and we
also need to keep these spaces here
clear to source these proper shots for
their colleagues with cameras at the
back there so Tuesday next week June 4
well mark 13 years since China's
military opened fire on demonstrators
and Tiananmen Square in Beijing it's
still of course my students because
there's been no credible independent
investigation of what happened today you
know we do have two speakers who were
directly involved in the Tiananmen
protests in 1989 and subsequently first
Polish mountain exile by China they're
here today - one of those that lost
their lives as well as many more that
faced subsequent punishment and
imprisonment by China's government our
first speaker today
the pain is a commentator on Radio Free
Asia and has the Chinese Alliance for
democracy the second speaker mr. Wayne
Graham now heads dialogue China which is
a us-based think tank mr. will speak
first
they've also advised me that their
comments will be really quite sure if
they want to go just a five or ten
minute introduction each short country
for Q&A as much to allows much time as
we can so if you could just join me in
welcoming our guests here today thank
you this year is 13th anniversary able
to enforce massacre
surgeries are 30 years ago
large-scale democratic movement was
launched in China their movement come
recently proved that in China freedom
and democracy were not only the pursuit
of a very small number of dissidents but
were the common aspiration of millions
of ordinary people
they're protesters set up a statue of
democracy in hemisphere
apparently modeled after the American
study of Liberty what is at time
everyone was convinced but the freedom
and the democracy were universal valid
not only applicable to the West but also
to China next the pardon walk claps and
the Soviet Union and the u.s. tea is the
Europe changed dramatically
the United States became the only
superpower in the world and the
democracies saw its greatest victory in
history at that time it was widely
believed not a CCP regime Mississippi
regimes days were numbered
however 30 years later the Suzuki regime
has not collapse in fact the dissident
firm unhung becomes stronger than before
contrary to many people's expectation
the CCP has not initiate any political
reform it has not become softer and more
tolerant because its greatest economic
success especially since he took office
the CCP regime has come more animal
accuracy meanwhile it is seems like
democracies including America
encountering a lot of trouble in just 30
years we have witnessed the huge
reversal in the world not happen in
extremely rare in the human history
looking back the history we can see that
a June 4th was the turning point the
chief was massacred not only ended China
the democratization process but also
they channeled the collective reform
can't a wrong path because of June 4th
democracy force in China was at rest and
the economic and the economic reforms
have since been carried out without
democracy with participation and the
public supervision
careful it became a prioritization by
the members of the Communist Party
themselves Suzuki are pressures in the
name of reform turned public assets into
their own private property therefore
making China the privatization process a
single state designation odd we know the
CCP loves to power by toppling Mandalore
and the capitalists but now it has
become the biggest landlord and the
capitalist in itself first in the name
of revolution which he turned as a
private property our common people into
the public property of the people as a
whole now in the name of the reform it
has returned as a public property of the
people of the whole into the private
property of its own numbers first it he
plundered in the name of revolution and
now it divided the spoiler in the name
of reform these two opposite crimes were
both committed by one and the same party
in the space of 17 years how the word
ever seen anything more shameless but
ironically ironically he also channels
proper privatization or the motive the
most shameless it was in kinetically the
most effective inspired by the
capitalistic mechanism chain of the
economy grew rapidly in addition China
took the global Express trick attracting
international capital under advanced
technology with an with the quantity of
law wages
and the low social warfare overhead
based on disregard for human rights thus
it becomes a multi credit rating form of
capitalism which he joined the strongest
caliber competitiveness hence there come
to be so-called Chinese model and also
the Chinese miracle however they lack
our dtt maseeh of is fatal to channel
the economy reform and the development
the so called Chinese Amato started out
as a massacre our tune fault is the best
on injustice it is in essentially a
process of open library the tea / such a
process goes they know unwilling this is
P necessity regime will be to implement
and the political reform therefore if he
must be competently all-powerful regime
that is contempt contempt errs and under
hostile to human rights democracy and
justice such a regime
thus necessarily is rate to the freedom
and peace of mankind this street will
only become more serious and dangerous
over time the marketing forces all over
the world children know the China's
problem is not only China's but also the
world and they should urgently unite to
prompt to promote to promote in
diversity regime one part dictatorship
and the China's transformation to
democracy where there's a steer time
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Sardar false time to hear
this
I actually have pretty much the same
opinions please mr. who better have an
application so have to say something
that's very important today to remember
what happened in chem mr. Clair's said
years ago definitely because we were
weak team came in readiness just because
of the whole world single we become care
for the sea cover the whole world
because they're increasing the time to
really recognize the true faith of China
what rights awakened learned from what
happened in 13 years that's the point I
want me I still remember when I was 20
years old when I was young and we went
was straight realized I have to add me
that we were naive why because we put a
hope on CCP that's the reason that maybe
the only reason we go to the street we
do now they did not want a response a
few changes of water trigger the country
but we could a hope on the CCP and we're
hopeful they can train to the country
that's why we went to straight and we
were now you after him a skirt and we
rely to the film diagnostic earth no
it's a democracy's a meal for CCP
whatever they open and reform and look
like liberal leaders that if you want
democracy
you are being a stable and you've stayed
that's the true CCP but it's only us and
then you wear that hand as in the whole
world
not only us the whole world
a year at a time after that apply the
masker the whole western country is cool
assumption China including including
Japan
remember after only two years they all
cut it off the assumption they distort
assumption one because they still
Western countries on the table
government still have hope for CCP
personally was passed they believe this
cooperation or engagement of is China
maybe China will have a rapidly Kaname
across there is they both have a middle
class democracy but after 30 years we
all realize it so thank you it's not
really arson are you the whole water
than you so my question is it's a kind
for us not for the whole democratic
countries no 2/3 recognize a true face
of CCP and try to learn some lessons
from Kim in Moscow this is a very
important challenge reward because no
attendance at reading power and simply
like a sweat for the democracy and the
freedom of the whole world this is a
very important to remember what happened
in canvas occurs 30 years ago so well I
don't need a table sir - government it's
the government's responsibility to try
to learn some lesson from their
relationship with China 30 years ago but
next questions now after 30 years China
become a powerful country I have a lot
of money and huge military force and
that's right for democratic countries
how can we solve this problem I already
say there is a trade
in their state and the China many the
future there are more troubles I sing
the China since if you have become a
troublemaker for the whole world
well how can we do this troublemaker I
said I remember when I was arrested
after with him a mass curve that was
arrest here twice I go shooting soon
interesting experience but that was
arrested twice and the third man turned
twice in jail finally I was released to
the US did I didn't die why because this
look because I'm kind of like a panda
you know it's you for trying about to
try to get something from the United
States in it they treated me to your
last day then President Clinton
countries I defeat you and that hand
just a link appear to intrude between
trade an economical usual and the humor
a TV shows analyze what I can be
released and you remember do so poor
it's even Nobel Prize winner and he died
in jail why because there's no link
between trade and human rights issues so
now China become as rightful freedom
world and in my opinion I think it is
time to relink tree and human rights
issues that may be a way to two ways
there is a problem and I know a lot of
Western countries tomorrow's meet their
relationship with China and they don't
say any regime change
hi panda in China but I have to say if
there's no rating changer nothing can be
resolved that's my point
we'll open the floor now to questions
from the media first please if you can
give you a name and affiliation and also
make clear who you're addressing your
question to be most appreciated I think
I would take the first question if you
don't mind - mr. Wang you said that
delinking trade from human rights so
could you comment on the approach of the
current US administration and how it's
it's dealing with China in terms of
trade sanctions you are you saying that
there should be an entirely separate
channel of communications with China on
human rights
what I mean that Raeleen country and
human rights issue what I mean is that
you'll have to put some human rights
issues in the list between negotiation
or single toilet area of China we're
located in Washington we've walked a bit
to other Signet hangars and
organizations will already provide or
such as sent to White House and the
Congress and also test is very simple
why tears treaty will be to you net
United State and attainment
why dere's trade imbalance between these
two countries there's two reasons where
it is the salaries are to lie too low
any for those workers what Rotolo then
the private made in China can be so
cheap there is the basic reason of the
economic imbalance so why don't you
prove the issue like the human right of
labor your talk with China this one
citizen another is that in tonight the
block of a in tonight harmed a lot of
benefit of a man
I mean if us involved in Tioga but if he
he transferred to Moodle now by him
please and re to tell you truth won't
undo your Shannon death also in in do
tooi Fant a year pungho
wasn't a ninja dog or Somali Jack worked
in a molecule friend number she didn't
eat her menses cash and social
networking co-leader we have come to
operated to the tune on that stovetop
attack that's how you Trish in the title
I think I think when Western trader to
entry the western country to entry with
China Western countries should emphasize
human right while they're doing the
trade with China with while they study
in the trading world with China and once
the Chinese people know that the
treating war is burning there dear can
you benefit from the trading war the
the Chinese people will not just the
believe what the Chinese government has
said so they will be more welcome the
westin they will be more supportive
for the training training or why we're
outside in the Congress eternal arena or
such as soon just because I say before
they do not want treaty may change
evenly no CCP is not their friend and
they did 30 years ago see where some
countries do want to redeem okay thank
you very much and Kenji kawase from
Nicky first of all my question is to is
to undone what can you enjoy my tea one
is how the regime change how how did how
do you deal with the issue of how is
very important I guess as you have
experienced in the past 30 years
publishing nothing has happened went to
the other direction of what you have
been trying to to pursue so and also not
only among the the people that China has
created the big camp and the
authoritarian camp within the the
democracy camp there's a huge range of
differences United States and maybe US
Congress may be very we were willing to
to force to push forward regime change
but maybe not here in Japan so the the
question of how especially after 30
years of going the other directions that
is my one my first question to do mister
and another one too - both of you
actually
is - this is like a personal question
don't you yeah sort of it tired of
talking about the same thing for past 30
years and nothing happens as she goes to
the other way because it seems like
there's like a progress I think you're
able to like push it through but now
that you don't have anything actually
you're your enemy as grown to that that
magnitude and you know you use the word
monster in Taipei if he was there at the
comfortably day conference if you
already created a monster and which is
very very hard to dis is connected to
the first question so please tell us
your personal opinion of how you feel
how you felt the past 30 years and and
how are you going to out push forward
for the next 30 years
thank you
could be very influential so what
happened well as there are a lot of this
kind of pressure from international
community and that I think of those
international pressures of work in that
world um so the unions case away I
believe it also will work on China's
case some international interfere like
Dinka trade and human rights issues all
the higher voice to advocate democracy
in China and it's not global time so I
see international media to something but
I do think if you want regime change
happening in China the Chinese people
take at the peak is based on ability but
if telling that democraty or now they're
also related to the benefit of Firstman
countries and the you have to two
centers and not only us not only
concerned for us social concern to use
second that I said you met it is very
important just like you say
CCP tried many ways the traders pad
European countries and the United States
so the Australia Japan England the
German and English state of work
together is very important it's not time
to fight each other you'll have a bigger
enemy this is my second semester from a
personal no yes I really tired of course
I'm 50 years over the 20 sale feel tired
you may utilize your time but but this
is my obligation I have two days I have
to take this responsibility one reason
and the reason just like you said
society become even bigger we meter
actually cannot say big a hole per year
future but I think what we are doing not
only for Zula dictatorship and also for
our self-respect ISA for dignity of
human being people are doing something
right in something we have to do no
matter what happening as a result so for
this reason I will never give up Taron
just certain young like ages at 10:20
Russia London nanny and career on track
yeah yeah so we like to go and hide we
hide in the kitchen yet you guys need to
tweak you de que pasa woman - mwah - ow
- even to the mantilla
or certain gotten warranty relevant here
so they also what an account how I got
teachers for those who taught wouldn't I
be on a trip or a Qaeda mental [ __ ] yet
society and gentleman wasn't able papa
Vernon to convince a young put up signs
in Yahoo the secretary under Google
mission the hybrid English la chica en
de Santiago see the potential here
of course talking about the same car
picker for 30 years it is boring however
I think it is still we still should talk
about it continue to talk about it
because just like what I said that June
4 Massacre and today's China's problem
is not a few numbers of the distance
topic and a problem it is the world is a
topic it should be world as a problem
and a world is topic so so I think after
the 30 years today especially we should
talk about this because this tightness
race has become has right in the world
and we the whole world should be alert
should it be a wired this problem
otherwise is imagined is it will be
imaginable what is what is going happen
what is going to be happen after next 30
years
thank you any other questions from the
floor
if not I have another question we had
two academics Chinese academics come and
speak here at the club I think a year or
two ago more than I've said Selina very
much interested me he said that the
biggest fear for Beijing's
current leadership the leadership of the
Communist Party the thing that keeps
them awake every night is Chinese
nationalism and the fear of nationalism
so he gave an example of there was
recently
the the shutdown of the number of South
Korean stores because South Korea degree
to place US missile batteries that can
supposedly be in range of China it
creates a lot of street protests and so
on and he said this kind of thing was
very much what the government feared
that one starts out on the streets to
protest severely it could get out of
control do you have any thoughts on man
of ears or comment is it Russian
Elizabeth II for most first of all is
there any real nationalism really
founded right if you if there's a strong
nationalistic of favor in young
generation how can you explain why is
for many people life that especially
those young generations what kind of
nationalism they say is so maybe yeah
academic term maybe we need another
trumpet recently the traditional
definition of nationalism you cannot use
this war to expand reality of the Train
now this is more Tommy let me back to
write it here yes I agree that
nationalism CCP and the she champion
really bound to be with a flag of a
national leader but it's really
dangerous for them because you I didn't
hang me if there are people over solvers
the carrier in the Strait is really I
think it's a tender father for the
government so I won handily values
national least take a favor but on
another country to Dominus 300 people
care together they put themselves in
this a trap
way them they come on right here Parton
velocity mean due to his bad ad
quadratum to was so fair and so him into
a conductance uncommon Georgia potential
I also think the government under the
outside world exactly that what what
what he said a national nationalism in
China it's a exaggerated you almost sold
out the poker in can come Gordon
changing yeah you can [ __ ] Oaxaca
cheese and chandâga so it finds you but
the front hour with other when he to
move him to put'em Attila Nadya Suleman
gender mission don't make you can tiara
should he run to work enduring
Thunderdome into the invitation do you
all know much Andy
Sandoval to one night for an economy
only no change in the Qin Jia when we
take he that uncommon me know cause of
it she's an occupant people to be chief
of the Teton senior wellness and
watching and geo-targeting I virginiana
women's hockey everything Jana reduces
the king yet so Anika we position our
even into talkative woman change Santini
go to China mayo de Mayo country
yagi antenna decision
so either way chia-chia we are called to
Latino so leanings of me okay
I think Chinese China's nationalism is
not strong at all under as I as I know
the several years ago there was a Medea
was many many
movement anti-japanese
until Western countries especially
anti-japan
it's not exist
anymore it's calm for a while and it's
gone soon and so China China's
nationalism is not strong at all
China's people we don't as as we our
generation and a young generation we
don't have experience about how Japan
invaded China and Akio Chinese and and
what what what experience we have is the
culture illusion is the hunger we
starving the starvation is the terrible
experience of the political movement so
I just cannot understand how come the
child is not a reasonable for Chinese
people they don't remember what they
really experienced but they only
remember the many years many years
happened something happened in many many
years like a Japan war like a especially
Western was started with in the 19th
centuries this is not possible
people forget they are real experience
and only remember the the remember
remember the sings the books the
government taught you is is ridiculous
is impossible
I also open the floor to maximize any
questions any associate members
freelancer from Germany I every time I
thought it's a kind of a feeling of
remembering that China was colonized by
the best on countries I say I've thought
about right sometimes
so China Pierrot still feels this kind
of humiliation by the foreign countries
and this is a reason to to make kind
China a very strong country and she said
I think this is a kind of a reason for a
kind of China and nationalism I think
one example every time of narrate a
chamber what happened with students in
in Australia perhaps so the China
student in Australia say protests a lot
against China's government or ChaCha the
Chinese cover our soil in government our
Australian scholar and toss tells them
every time to not not at or to talk
against the china's china government so
i mean this is this is not a kind of
nationalism how is the question for
saturated
when students and insists in their
foreign countries reactances ray this is
not a kind of a nationalism for fancy
students and this is not a kind of firm
but only she shouldn't think so I think
do not many Chinese people think in this
way do that to say not have she's
feeling for humiliation go under and to
want to have a strong China country
again in Beijing our generation the
nationalistic speedy because we bring
about the to something for our country
make it better that no a very big impact
of Moscow is make the whole generation
of indeed collectively give up your
responsibility for this country and
that's why they lack that country so
some middle-class intellectuals young
researchers so how can imagine
nationalism if if the whole elite class
they just want to relax in this country
there's no room for ending nationally so
that's my sorry I'm losing I even don't
think it airs nationally in China at all
or decoration key for them in return
faith honey is okay but they write they
treat well they were seeking just a
manager to doctrine war
I think the gentleman's question is very
interesting because how to read the
China today is a very important thing to
mentality rescission um she should
happen door
twirling a change for now mr. Chang was
a creepy or the other
hahaha woman and Joe acaba Chamma Chamma
Chamma Chamma take a part of your face
on sinful adventure Oh China Oh Chinese
people today inside the China mostly
inside China someone Inza are also China
- they know clearly what they should say
what they should not say what they
should express what kind of feeling they
should express what kind of emotion they
should not express even you get kinda
tell you yes sure till here hockey Paulo
demo hehehe from whadya dad your hands
intro woman agency created our take on
the fact that I said oh no kids have you
here until then you know this is no not
numbers hack job
she went to put yeah I'll make you put
on them at all that's why you can see
many Chinese people you know outside in
oversea Chinese they can do they can
have a very strong pause to Western
government because they know they have
they are saiful to protest the Western
government but a flood Simpson happened
if something happened that same in China
they wouldn't see anything because they
know they can't they shouldn't she know
to win title video taping he touch
unfortunately he haven't either show
Rupert America is absorbing film into
the Jennifer I'm afraid Hampton de to me
on the Haunted on New York and Chicago
she returned for condom that one
decision ten-foot tycoon war Camuto
dream but already the door the second
when many Chinese people live ours
overseas in democratic countries whence
they encounter any problem they know
very well how to protest and how to use
the democratic system to protect
themselves but if the same thing
happened in China even were serious
things happening in China they they
wouldn't do anything they would keep
silent so channel EXO adjacent emoticons
young sometimes from the content and
even commercially for the means o2e
Michigan ha thought with the tween the
teeming go with the G quickly so that's
why I think in China today is not some
pure nationalism or simple you can you
can just this you cannot a describe a
Chinese people as a simple nationalism
what in my opinion Chinese people today
is too smart as to opportunities they
just use any chance to protect to
protect themselves that's it yes
Thank You Jessie Johnson with the Japan
Times I have two quick questions for you
like first time is given that the
Communist Party is basically effectively
erase the memory of gentlemen what can
Japan do to help preserve the memory in
the face of patriotic education in China
and the improving sooner Japanese
relationship what what can Japan do
realistically to help bring the memory
keep the number your life is the first
question the second question is would
you say that you mentioned earlier Japan
was one of the first countries to kind
of invite China back into the fold after
chairman would you say would you assign
at least some kind of partial blame to
Japan for being so quick to have China
come back after Johnson first to some
conflict between Japan and China
we cannot attend to that as Easter
already happened we have to made uh some
new history and I believe this new
history must be based on our foundation
of democracy I mean has this
responsibility to promote or have to
promote a democracy in China but I know
that means come in a very realistic but
I don't think it's a right choice
so did you also know they can do like
United State they have
nationally endorsement Norfolk
immigrants a huge foundation from the
lot of the NGOs inside inside of China
it's very helpful for civil societies in
China even Taiwan has this kind of
foundation to support civil society and
the secondary a lot of human rights
abuse happening in China including
charting of poor but I never say
Japanese common don't look up our CEO
Jetta suprafacial inflation phenomenal
and he/she solution to city and to
Newton here shaking thing I mean those
booties yeah Portugal it's friendlier
but should say I don't think it's a
Jaguar 500 chairman Gong cha far from
the Kumu Kahua Grigio found the tragedy
the 10th Union here so if I determine
the P Audrey don't are totally action
conference and Indonesia it is important
to keep the memory of June 4th actually
June 4th Massacre government a crackdown
a student movement is not the first is
not the first I know it will not be the
last
actually June 4th Massacre is not the
most serious time the government
crash democratic movement it is just
because you know June 1st happened in
front of the TVs all over the world so
it become most important thing
okay from Kabul Shantanu one dose 20,000
people
oh yeah Santiago pardon England Pandi
dosha Technovation Delta murican don't
the dosa to come into pachinko I mean
you put it out here is what I call a
commercial associate Afonso Tom Thomas
to the hybrid how many but I was him
indeed the the people who participated
June 4th not June 4th 1989 movement as a
lot almost all beta knees participated
that movement how I work today you can
ask many Chinese people and they don't
know
June 4th they don't know that movement
even many people come to the overseas
they have the free information but we
still do not know to enforce or 1989
movement mmm
tempo Honduran podía those Portugal Rosa
even honey intra God coming it is very
simple when people said they don't know
1989 student movement or they don't know
June for massacre the reason is they
already know mmm they don't do not get
any on the show tell your pocket another
chocolate ocean to start with a picot
put on de genève it a try and una
fair event of a type of gravy the title
- John - Manohar who the young Buddha
him bhava you hear when click hi I'm
guna second don't you retire oh you
don't show up or belittling t it is it
is simple just because because the
when we when in our experiences
when we encounter many many problems we
don't want to tell our children the bad
experience because it's to suffering too
painful so we don't want to tell our
young generation our kids what happened
in our life will just be old the Chinese
saying is them if I don't say it I
thought I don't listen to it I would not
just know it near my family I wish him
to abandon pooja to yan xishan
jean dousset ring hey push it to the
answer don't be a [ __ ] I'm Raja tendon
the tobu to deduce the chicken riggies
Ampata Hydra continue to know all the
sea to do so to take a chef attention do
that me he got to warn the Hindi China's
because the Fiat June force massacres of
fear is still stay in every Chinese mind
that does that's very heavy for every
Chinese Tagalog an entire patent yeah
yeah you're the audience to run the
jungle chunk of the top one didn't maybe
see me they don't come if a face on TV
official corrida
that can run her fate my hinder or
Tantra yoga horse farm mature so that
she gets her share her pocket for coming
away with the hindi aruna nama tuna
Serena protein and conversion to support
that was this is the kanji Tigger she's
a pendulum the hint I could hear you
laugh it her not as idiot if you if you
ever visit a China before the June for
mass massacres
you should know that and that's hi mo
during that time Chinese people has a
full of hope for Western for Western
system for the democracy for freedom
there they were very happy and that time
they you should know that no one and
that homo is afraid of the government
they they they go to the street the
protester they are not afraid of the
government the full of hope in their in
their heart excuse me however today
people the June for massacre made the
people have a lot of a fear inside they
you cannot say they don't know June
force at all no the today the
information is so open they shouldn't
know and they have the opportunity to
know but they don't want to know because
the fear
stop them - no one swipe you want to
keep the fear inside well why if the if
they already so afraid of the government
how one hope how come they wanted to
know the truth and finish today
so agent we work I need to keep him yeah
I agree with one done ten years ago even
Lucia boy write article and show has
disappointed with the Western Community
Credit Union to what we can decision
should be some you can say look at
Makaha Academy attack
but however I think is understandable
for Western societies active actions
because in my opinion today what
happened in China is new for the world
no one really understand it and
understand China no one know how to read
the China how to deal with China now so
three years ago people thought when
China became big economic power there
should be a market economy in China but
so far the party economy is the biggest
among those economic power do you think
that what people thought 30 years ago is
just an impossible dream or you can
still have some kind of market economy
in China
a tough question
well parent tidal city hall talking to
our 19 ahartry ho not too much junk on
Jan says so - yeah it sort of hanging at
the port side yes I think after June 4th
after 1989 China opened the market and
step in the free market society that
enough time to borders didn't serve and
we curtseyed have a super new yo cheerio
had not put home for the China's
capitalism is very different from the
traditional capitalism Joseph in ya
rotten food items away have a coffee
grinder Tony Turner say your commitment
is to mention China Sea China's when the
process of China open market and become
economic reform is very different from
the world in China after June 4th they
they started the economic development
and the reform is just big just you just
later the Aurora Chinese Communist Party
member of in Chinese officials become
the CEO become the leader of the company
directly yet how many segments in Japan
and on radiative support here so listen
to imitate others - the Chinese then the
Chinese officials and
[Music]
[Music]
our survey team an account which I
totally agree with wrong done and we can
imagine if someone else sit in the
position of them shopping at that time
who cannot make this area he cannot a
crackdown such a bigger movement because
his his not have that kind of things
europeans reputation and the power
analysis about her was the reason canvas
to the movement afire but i history
major student
sometimes maybe officially not so
complicated maybe just a very very
simple because of you still an amazing
if there's no time something I think
Chelsea on terms of Yahoo air crocodile
student movement and I do think somebody
can have this kind of a power to carve
down all the other days I've seen yes so
maybe that's only reason for our failure
okay we don't have to finish their
semi-final responsibilities days to
extend to mister mister burn the
one-year complimentary membership for
the FCC J okay
[Applause]